was honestly one of Mitt Romney's best
political moments when he announced he
was going to retire rather continue to
see terms because he was like if I run
again I will be in my 80s and that's too
old and you know that that's not a
terrible Point again I'm not saying that
Trump shouldn't run and not saying that
everyone who's in their ad80 is in the
position Joe Biden is in but we can't
say that we're like this young spry
country there was a reason that JFK had
such an influence on politics right that
he was young he had these kids a
beautiful wife whatever else well Trump
is spry well and this was one of the
appeals for santis at in the beginning
people were comparing him you know to
this young he's got young children
whatever else got a young wife there was
sort of this idea that it was sort of a
brush of FR air this was before I think
Trump announced obviously there's more
contention now I'm not trying to weigh
on on that on his heel but then Biden
but then uh uh not Biden then Des santis
showed up to school wearing high heels
and everyone went hey look new kids
wearing high heels and he went shut up
no I'm not we high heel